bonjour est ce que pour vous c'est une
bonne chose ce report de la réforme des
retraites et de l'assurance chômage
alors oui c'est une bonne chose
on aurait pu faire mieux en demandant
que en proposant pardon ça aurait été
mieux que le premier ministre nous
disent qu'ils abandonnaient ces deux
réformes là je crois qu'il faut les
traiter de façon différente
c'est à dire que la réforme de
l'assurance chômage qui est la réforme
de 2 juillet de l'année dernière elle
s'était elle s'est faite dans un
contexte économique qui désormais
n'existe plus et n'existera plus dans
les années qui viennent en tout cas
pendant un certain moment c'était moi je
les qualifiait une réforme anti chômeurs
alors qu'elle est censée être une
réforme pour s'attaquer au chômage en
vérité que s'attaque aux chômeurs en les
culpabilisant en prétendant dans les
outils qu'elle met en place que le
chômeur est quelqu'un qui ne recherchent
pas activement du travail
on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui la donne est
complètement bouleversé on a un million
de chômeurs supplémentaires qui pour
beaucoup sont des travailleurs qui
étaient avant en intérim ou en cdd et on
prévoit effectivement une augmentation
encore du nombre de chômeurs à la
rentrée avec les jeunes qui sont censés
rentrer sur le marché de l'emploi
donc on va être confronté à une
problématique intense un très profonde
vis à vis des gens qui demanderont de
l'emploi qui se retrouveront face à des
perspectives économiques d'intégration
relativement faible est médiocre c'est à
la première fois qu'il ya une crise
économique on le sait il y en a il y en
a déjà eu probablement aucune n'aura
atteindre l'intensité de cette crise là
donc tout ce qui est dans le contenu de
la réforme sur un chômage n'est plus
qualifié aujourd'hui il faut
effectivement l'abandonner je suis assez
en désaccord avec le premier ministre
quand il dit que c'est une bonne réforme
non c'est une mauvaise réforme et
concernant la réforme des retraites
justement la mise de travail l'a rappelé
ce matin dans une interview au parisien
il s'agit d'une pause sur la réforme des
retraites
c'est très simple le gouvernement depuis
deux ans maintenant un qui nous a
proposé de travailler de réfléchir à ce
projet le système est unique par points
prétend que c'est un système qui est
plus juste plus équitable plus
équilibrée plus visible nous nous
attendons exactement le contraire et
nous avons des éléments pour le
démontrer je pense qu'aujourd'hui il n'y
a plus personne ne peu sérieux qui peut
défendre ce système là son seul objectif
c'est de diminuer les pensions
alors si le gouvernement était venu vers
nous en disant je vais mettre en place
un système pour les retraites qui
permettra de diminuer les pensions
il aurait dit la vérité et sur cette
base là on aurait pu discuter parce que
je n'aime pas dans ce débat sur la
réforme des retraites c'est qu'elle est
portée par un discours qui est en fait
un discours à ses mensonges et donc
aujourd'hui le premier ministre est une
bonne mesure qui est une mesure
d'apaisement il dit nous repoussons
l'examen finalement la discussion sur le
système unis nous repoussons ça l'année
prochaine notre priorité c'est la crise
économique ces plans de relance
il a raison moi je soutiens cette
décision est par ailleurs il nous
demande d'être attentifs aux équilibres
financiers des différents systèmes
sociaux il a raison aussi moi je suis
prêt à le suivre je me déporterai pas
sûr c'est très large habilité nous avons
tous ensemble d'examiner les équilibres
financiers et là justement comment
est-ce que vous jugez ses premiers
échanges avec le nouveau premier
ministre
jean castex et évoque une nouvelle
méthode qu'on attendez-vous à la cfe cgc
en un mot parce que le temps du manque à
excuser moi oui non la nouvelle méthode
le premier ministre veut instaurer un
climat de confiance
c'est un engagement il a un discours
assez cohérents sur le sujet il
semblerait que il souhaite mettre les
actes en cohérence avec son discours sur
le respect des partenaires sociaux moi
je m'avance en confiance avec lui
j'espère que on aura la confirmation
dans l'agenda
dans les jours dans les semaines dans
les mois qui viennent que ce discours
est concret qu'il s'incarne et que les
partenaires sociaux vont réellement
rentrer dans le jeu et nous suivrons
avec attention merci beaucoup pour votre
réaction françois mary président de la
cfe cgc